hello and welcome to video playing years
over HOF that is not the way to
pronounce it all I'm very certain with
black and he plays a double fee and
Carol yeah I checked this I can actually
this is the setup that I play against
the English you can play against this so
I mean it doesn't have to play he didn't
play c4 but it's okay it's a bit
different it is definitely a bit
different
okay d4 is he threatening to take on c6
only and only five I have to be a super
materialistic player to take this give
up the LightSquared bishop here okay
here I can take with the noid
[Music]
if he's really afraid of getting chicken
made that he can take a five and trade
Queens but that is not him he's doing it
that is definitely not a critical line
where black has to fear anything they
should definitely try to Queens him if
he takes on e5 in the first place you
should take on the ED Knight c3 maybe
unless taking a long while him
what on earth are you doing there okay
now he decided to take this is um I mean
as I mentioned it cannot be a really
critical move to take but he's got
decent pieces now and my bishop on a7 is
not yet not yet effective
I wonder if now it's very difficult as I
get now I can start with this move I
wonder divided is possible to play
without c6 but yeah you never get get c8
developed if you don't play c6 but you
can maybe wait for one move until you do
it
ninety five takes rook takes f6 should
be okay for me
okay Bishop g4 maybe hmm I wonder if
that is in in something it doesn't make
a real huge difference I mean yeah I can
I can do that but it is it is a bit
annoying you know
let's move you cannot go I have three
due to the due to this and he has to
play rook t2 now more or less maybe King
f1 okay King f1 isn't terrible
you know King f1 maybe Ruka h2 it can be
a bit a bit of an bit of an annoyance
really let's see what he does he plays
that move okay so let's do it let's make
let's threaten something I'm actually I
haven't have even more ideas so then
every initially thought because if he
moves the bishop let's say to e4 I can
take on e3 do to that x-ray that that
x-ray Bishop and rook so what is his
move if he has to play rook T - yeah
it's going up detune but that's I mean
that that's not very comfortable and
with the rook sexy six years to go to d3
it looks it looks fishy that looks fishy
and for him somehow
hmm hmm I have an idea rook t3 Bishop f5
if he goes Eve for rook g2 now that wins
the pot rock g2 and I'm threatening on
f2 as well so he cannot go like eat eggs
f5 I hope I hope I mean there's a big
Luke d7 at the end of this stuff and so
yeah maybe he can do that so let's take
this and unfortunately I cannot play
anything to stop him
they're from rook d7 that's a bit of a
pain really just will be a Don
yeah maybe just rupee 8jj check it's not
not really that ideal
[Music]
I'm just taking f5 I don't know I have
to make a move
maybe I mean on time okay now I'm
definitely definitely winning if he if
he doesn't have an active move on the
eighth-ranked okay let's take the
important f-pawn nante results only just
on time him okay so let's have a look so
after age form he decided to yeah yeah
sort of
it's it's a recommended line the engine
already is kind of yeah fears blanks
attack home understandably I think the
age file is it's going to be dangerous
so so heat this take take rookie one
King to e7 or very normally I'm not f6
or c6 probably not a huge difference it
checked f6 yeah normal all very normal
and now yeah so take take Bishop g4 and
now so the computer wants to go v 2d -
instead of King f1 king of 1 and rook
age 2 so the engine prefer c6 here going
back and then just like a5 Bishop oops
sorry Bishop c5 like just grind with the
bishop and that's that's a way to do it
of course I extended stuff I wanted to
post more concrete problems and it
worked
yeah to some extent here Bishop f5 yeah
and now he forgives me the pawn but yeah
the way it turned out I wasn't super
Shaun so this was kind of forced and
here Luke takes a5 yeah me I kind of
suspected that this is right but I
couldn't quite I didn't want to allow
him to take on b7 at all I thought he
can still take on b7
and this is probably wrong in yeah it's
totally wrong because of this idea ah
okay
that means be seven here was covered
technically now I'm threatening made the
Lucas saying he's got no check so then
this is a mistake
and in fact Yahoo 37 is drunk Knight to
f4 Wow oh my goodness that's that that
would have shocked me real him Knight f4
yeah it's a very strong move it's just a
very strong move
I mean if I take this he's going to
check me and then he's got a super
active positioner the rook the knight
the the evaluation of zero is quite
believable I have by the engine white is
so active that I cannot do much and what
else I can take here when we get to look
ending when I'm a pawn up but okay yeah
this is so strong like you cannot move
that's very very lucky also just to draw
and the way it turned out he couldn't
really do all that much he has no good
square like he I just move it and yeah
he had this opportunity night F formed
and I should definitely not play b8 but
it was the was the moment where I was
kind of thinking about it and then okay
I have to make a move the alternatives
we'll look at five and means this sorry
looks this way because I'm threatening
like somewhat made not quite made it
only the night and I would rob yeah okay
a tough game thanks a lot for watching